c'est une étape à domicile de la
campagne de valérie pécresse devant 900
personnes au total la candidate au
congrès les républicains est venu parler
de sa capacité à porter les couleurs de
son parti pour l'élection présidentielle
à travers son parcours politique
l'expérience de la miss l'université
4000 neuf mois face à la rue et fait
l'une des réformes est plus difficile du
quinquennat sarkozy de l'ami du budget
qui a géré les finances de la france
pendant la crise des dettes souveraines
de la présidente de région
qui s'est battue qui a conquis une
région et qui la dirige alors que c'est
une région à la fois urbaine et rurale
riches mais aussi très inégalitaire dans
la salle du théâtre national de
saint-quentin-en-yvelines de nombreuses
connaissances de valérie pécresse des
sénatrices des conseillers
départementaux et régionaux ou encore
des maires de commune yvelinoise
aujourd'hui je pense que c'est la seule
qui est sincère ou c'est la plus sincère
avec ses convictions et c'est la seule
qui a montré qu'elle pouvait aller
entraîner
les citoyens sur un sujet pour réformer
la france sans changer d'avis au gré des
sondages c'est quelqu'un qui fait
et c'est vraiment ce que le besoin le
pays a besoin aujourd'hui arrêtons les
discours les promesses les jeux les
manipulations de chiffres c'est
quelqu'un de sérieux moi je dirais que
en plus c'est quelqu'un qui fait ce
qu'elle dit mais il y avait aussi des
militants les républicains qui n'ont pas
encore fait leur choix hopla d'hésiter
il faut un caractère une personnalité
rassembleur et quelqu'un qui en impose
parmi nos alliés et nos ennemis
potentiels face à valérie pécresse
quatre candidats xavier bertrand michel
barnier eric ciotti et philippe juvin le
premier tour du congrès se tiendra du
mercredi 1er au jeudi 2 décembre avant
un second tour du vendredi 3 au samedi 4
décembre jour où l'on connaîtra le
candidat les républicains à la
présidentielle 2022